goodbye my son
absent range traveled here
you've been outcast oh wow
we'll be of God to them
have done they use a different
technology for their displays through
this technology that we called liquid
gia the stem from an idea that Zack
Snyder had he he wanted to do something
that you know was was interesting and
different in the way that you saw
information presented he didn't want to
do just a typical screen and so one of
the ideas that Zack had was to make it a
little bit more tactile the shapes
really need to transform you need
something that has that look but has to
be in a sense more liquid you came from
Krypton the way we created the display
shapes was through a combination of
animation and simulation and once that
animation was going to finalized the
effects Department would run simulations
on top of that animation in addition to
just the form you also need the lighting
that was the thing that we discovered as
we were really you know looking into and
trying to make it work and so what we
tried to come up with was this kind of
hybrid technique that would allow us to
to kind of develop these forms on the
fly so they they had this this sort of
metallic liquid droplet kind of feel but
it felt tactile long ago and an era of
expansion I'll race spread out through
the stones
seeking new worlds to settle upon
there's a sequence in the film where
jor-el who is Superman's father teaches
him about where he came from what what
life was like on Krypton we did a lot of
experimentation to figure out what this
history of Krypton would look like we we
started with just the liquid bgo kind of
technology itself and that was
reasonably straightforward we did quite
a lot of concept art we really just sort
of explored those kind of aesthetic
looks but applied to spaceships and
aliens and tried to figure out what that
might look like the tiny beads of
geometry move around and form new
surfaces and those surfaces move as well
so you'll have little bits of almost
kind of stylized greco-roman bar relief
kind of look and we simplified the
shapes down a little bit and made them
kind of graphic and bold in some ways
like art deco a little bit as well
Oh
[Music]